and families are morning loved ones lost
to a senseless act of gun violence as
some of the victims families have said
we are starting Lunar New Year broken
to read their stories is indeed
heartbreaking stories like the 65 year
old who went to the dance studio in
Monterey Park on weekends because it's
what she loved to do
and tragically her family said that
Saturday was her last dance
we've read moving tributes for the
former dance student who helped manage
the studio from his fellow dancers and
his teachers
a grandmother whose family described how
hard she worked to give back to her
community and care for her loved ones
died after being taken to the hospital
in critical condition
we have mourn lives lost in mass
shootings after mass shootings the flags
at the White House were already at half
mast in honor of those murdered in
Monterey Park when we learned of the
shooting in Half Moon Bay
President Biden like most Americans
believes that this is an urgent issue
that too many of our neighbors
colleagues kids are losing their lives
to gun violence over the last two
decades more school-aged children have
died from guns than on-duty police
officer and active duty military
combined
and we know what the policy Solutions
are we know how we can address this in
fact Last Night senator Feinstein along
alongside Senators Murphy Blumenthal and
others reintroduced a federal assault
weapons weapons and high capacity
magazine ban and legislation that would
raise the minimum purchase age
four assault weapons 221
the last time we had an assault weapons
ban on the books thanks to the president
and Senator Feinstein's leadership mass
shootings actually went down
after Republicans let it expire mass
shootings tripled and that's just a fact
as you all know President Biden has
taken historic executive action to
reduce gun violence and last summer he
signed the bipartisan safer communities
Act the first significant piece of gun
safety legislation in nearly 30 years
but he but he continues to believe and
these tragic events continue to show us
there is more to be done to keep our
home schools and communities safe the
president and the first lady are
thinking of those killed and injured in
these latest shootings Across America
but more importantly he's urging both
chambers of Congress to act quickly and
deliver this assault bans assault
weapons ban
to his desk and take additional action
to keep American Community Schools
workplace and homes safe I also wanted
to share exciting news about President
economic plan continuing to create
results for Americans across the country
today we learned 38 states are now at
our at or below 4
unemployment and States from
Pennsylvania to South Dakota to Alaska
have record low unemployment
we also know a record 10.7 million jobs
were created in the last two years
annual inflation has fallen over the
last six months the economic the economy
grew at 3.2 percent in the most recent
GDP report and a record 10.5 million
small businesses applications were filed
since the president took office
and we're continuing to lower health
care costs for Americans a new report
shows that if inflation reduction acts
insulin cap were implemented in 2020 1.5
million Senators across the country
could have saved an average of 500 per
year on insulin the inflation reduction
acts Health Provisions including
permanent Affordable Care Act subsidies
and Medicare negotiations down Medicare
negotiating down certain prescription
drugs mean more money in Americans
pockets and more breathing room for
American families as the president said
in a statement this morning and I quote
Americans are seeing a strong economy
where they live they are seeing their
neighbors back to work with higher wages
even even accounting for inflation
they're seeing prices down at their
pharmacies they are they're seeing new
businesses opening with the most with
most Americans applying to start small
businesses at any time on record and
quote and finally I wanted to say hello
and welcome to the park school of
Baltimore students they're lined up to
my left here who are here for uh for
their their career career exploration
day and welcome welcome students I had
an opportunity to meet all of you very
impressive and I know High School could
be a lot of fun but also very hard just
stay focused keep your passion and
you'll get there so good to see you all
with that armor good to see you
um so first I just wanted to ask is
there any uh reaction uh to vice
president Pence's announcement finding
classified docs in his possession and
then more broadly most of the rules
surrounding classification are created
and can be amended by executive order
does the president believe the system
must be performed so first on your first
question look I'm not going to comment
on any ongoing a criminal investigation
or any investigation as you all know the
Department of Justice is independent and
we will not politically interfere we've
been very very clear about that under
this President the president's been very
clear since his campaign uh promises and
so I'm just going to refer you to
Department of Justice on your second
question I would refer you to the White
House counsel's Office the last one on
Ukraine
um is the administration ready to give
Abrams to Ukraine in order uh I just won
already this is the administration ready
to give the Abrams and two
um if you are is there is a been
connected with Germany also giving
leopards so I'm going to say we're in
concert Communications with Ukraine and
other allies and partners as it relates
to what Ukraine's needs in the
battlefield but I don't have any preview
anything to preview here any
announcements to make at this time of
any new types of security assistance to
preview for you today
Department to search his Rehoboth Beach
house again I would refer you to the
White House counsel's Office who have
been regularly in touch with all of you
answering these questions about about
this legal legal ongoing matter just
don't have anything to share and a
couple follow-ups on the Pence issue
does the White House believe that the
justice department should appoint a
special counsel to investigate former
vice president Pence's handling of
classified documents that's for the
Department of Justice to decide and now
that we're seeing the two most recent
vice presidents discover classified
documents in their private homes does
this suggest that there's a larger
problem within the government where
classified documents are not where
they're supposed to be do a lot of
people have documents outside of where
they're properly supposed to be strong
I'm not going to comment from from here
on that I would refer you to the White
House Council on any anything related to
classified documents from here
next screen on the issue of gun control
you spoke about the president's
commitment to the assault weapons ban
and his view that there is more that can
be done how does how do I should say the
limitations in Congress I.E with the
votes that you have or don't have on
Congress impact that
View and what can you be more specific
about what he thinks can be done
given the votes that he has now so I
just want to remind folks that this is a
president who has made gun violence and
dealing with gun violence his uh his
career and he's actually been very very
instrumental in pushing uh pushing
forward uh these types of gun reforms
that we have seen whether it is uh what
we saw with the assault weapons ban 30
years ago that he he helped get done
with Senator Feinstein or signing the
bipartisan uh piece of legislation that
he signed into law just months ago that
was again the most significant piece of
a piece of legislation that dealt with
gun violence and let's not forget he has
made this a priority for him for him in
his presidency since day one with
historic executive action so I say all
of this to say is this is a priority for
the president when folks thought we
wouldn't be able to get a bipartisan
deal done on dealing with gun violence
that was able to uh that was uh that was
able to get done with because of the
president's leadership on this because
of the president's focus on this look we
are always looking for his team is
always looking for ways to to do to
continue with gun to do executive
actions to deal with reducing gun
violence but what we believe uh is that
Congress needs to act they need to put
forth legislation that can go into law
and deal with this issue we cannot
continue to see communities be
devastated by this as a parent we should
not be waking up every morning worried
that our child or our kids may have to
deal with gun violence if you're going
to the grocery store you should not have
to worry about going to the grocery
store and potentially having to deal
with gun violence or going to the movies
watching a movie with your partner or
with your kids and eating popcorn and
wait and potentially having to worry
about gun violence and so the president
has been very clear and this is not just
the last two years this has been the
many decades of his career so we're
going to have to continue to have those
conversations with Congress we're going
to continue to call on Congress to take
action
U.S officials have determined that
Chinese companies have been sending
non-lethal assistance to Russia for
Ukraine
um what is the United States saying to
the Chinese government about so we're
closely monitoring the situation as we
have been since the war started we will
continue to communicate to China the
implications of providing material
support to Russia's war against Ukraine
we we have talked about this many times
that we we will you know be very clear
what it means to support Russia's
aggression against Ukraine and as I've
said many times as my colleagues from
NSC has said many times we'll continue
to support Ukraine and Ukrainian people
as long as needed
I'm not going to get into uh diplomatic
or private conversations from here I'm
just going to let you know that we've
been monitoring the situation and we've
been very clear with with uh with the
Chinese government on this thanks for
any talk about how cabaze the priority
for this Administration it's been a
priority for the president over his
entire career how does he feel in
moments like last night his frustration
is it helplessness personally how does
he deal with this continuing to be a
major problem you know Phil I would say
that you've seen him out there sadly
with many of these uh tragedies uh
mourning with the families
offering his support to families and it
is uh it continues you'll you continue
to what you see from him is certainly
how he feels when he sees these types of
travesties you saw that in Uvalde sadly
when we saw kids were gunned down where
families had to identify the the way
they would identify their own children
was through DNA that's how horrible that
situation was you saw him in Buffalo New
York meeting with the 10 members the 10
victims who were killed and him meeting
with those families and dealing with
their heartache and so this is a
president that feels right that is able
to feel what people are going through
because he knows what loss means to
families so yeah you know he wants to
continue to fight he wants to continue
to speak out against this you've seen
his statements over the last several
days sadly on what we have seen with gun
violence across the country
and so you'll continue to see that and
he will continue to speak about this in
a way that lifts up the families who are
who are dealing with this loss very
devastating loss and continue to call on
Congress to take action one more shot on
the uh on the Pence documents is there
any sense inside the White House that
this perhaps shifts the political or
public perception dynamics of what the
president has been facing over the
course of the lesson weeks I'm just not
going to comment from here
get Joey
I thought you were there yesterday but
it was Michael I apologize Michael
update on whether the president plans to
visit California I know you were asked
yesterday but since then there's as
we've noted there was a second uh mass
shooting there so I no no plans at this
time to preview about a president uh
presidential travel to California you
saw his statement I just kind of read
part of his statement his heart his
heart goes out to the families uh to the
victims of the families and um and we
will continue to fight to make sure we
deal with this issue we deal with gun
violence we started with the executive
actions the historic executive actions
that the president was able to do the
first two years of his administration we
were able again as I mentioned sign a
bipartisan piece of legislation to deal
with gun violence but we need to do more
we need to do a lot more and so the
president's going to continue to call
for that I don't have anything to
preview about our trip yeah and you were
kind of alluded to this or asked a
little bit about this but I mean what is
the strategy now to pass uh uh the
assault weapon span that uh Feinstein
introduced I mean you're talking of
course about a republican-led house now
uh and so how I mean you know what can
the White House do to actually overcome
those those numbers yeah and one thing I
just want to go back to on California
the president has been in touch with
local and state leaders and his his team
continues to offer support uh to uh the
local government and clearly um uh
Governor newsom's team in any way that
we can to be helpful to what they're
dealing with today uh this week I should
say uh look it is you know it is a
priority for the president it really is
that's why he's taken executive actions
that's why his team has worked with
Congress uh on this bipartisan
legislation that was passed several
months ago and he'll continue to do that
and you know I think if you all remember
and many of you reported this that that
how difficult it was going to be for the
president to get any bipartisanship the
first two years of in his administration
and he was able to get history work
pieces of legislation done and so the
President says this all the time he
isn't he's he's optimistic and uh you
know and I think optimism is very
important to this president but at the
same time he's going to continue to ask
Congress to act and uh and he's going to
continue to see what other executive
actions can be taken from here but at
the end of the day we need Congress act
we need legislation that can be signed
into law to deal with a matter that is
really tearing apart communities
it's great
um was the White House aware before this
afternoon that classified documents had
been found at vice president Pence's
residence as well I would refer you to
the White House council's Office does
the White House believe that other
former High office holders should now go
back and check their personal residences
out of an abundance of caution to make
sure that they're not holding on to
classified documents as well that's not
something I can comment from here I
don't even we don't I don't even know
the uh you know the the reasoning of
what the news that we heard about Pence
so I'm just not going to comment from
here I'm not going to comment on any
other former elected official current
elected official with this particular
case I referred to Department of Justice
anything that relates to this white
house I would refer you to the White
House counsel's office and then on the
Abrams tank last week at the podium John
on Kirby said that the Abrams is
expensive to maintain to operate to fuel
and there requires a lot of training
does this White House still have those
same concerns when it comes to providing
tanks to the Ukrainian so as my DOD
colleagues have said very recently that
again nothing to preview from here uh
certainly don't have anything to share
but they never ruled out tanks just want
to make that very clear I think what my
colleagues at the dod have said in the
past well very recently is that there's
there were always challenges with uh
tanks but not going to preview anything
I think I would refer you to the dod
comments on this again they've always
been challenges it's never been taken
off the table but as I just mentioned I
don't have anything to preview those are
the challenges what are the benefits to
the potential I mean we've already we've
always said again nothing to preview
want to be very clear here we've always
said that we are in constant
communication with Ukraine as their as
their are trying to figure out what they
need on the battlefield and and we are
always looking for ways to offer
security security assistance for them
and so again not going to get ahead of
any any potential announcement I'm not
don't have anything for you to preview
for to preview but we're always in
constant communication with Ukraine and
what it is that they need for their
success what it is that they need to
really battle the aggression that we
have seen from uh from Russia this
almost past year
it's great uh Germany's ruling party
just confirmed that they've decided to
send leopard tanks to Ukraine do you
have any comment on that and is that
linked to in any way uh reversal
this consideration of U.S government San
Diego Abrams to ukrain as well so we
have said this before we believe it's up
to each individual country it is uh
their own Sovereign Sovereign decisions
on what they provide for Ukraine we've
been very clear about that and we always
appreciate what our allies our partners
are doing to make sure that Ukraine is
able to defend itself I'm not going to
go beyond that again don't have anything
to preview from here the switching
topics on uh on Ticketmaster there was
this hearing of the Senate today given
the White House's concern about Monopoly
power does the White House believe the
Live Nation Ticketmaster merger should
be Unwound given what we've heard today
from Senators expressing that concern
are you a Swifty is that what it's
called I don't know
things that you learn
um so look President Biden is a strong
proponent of increasing competition in
our economy as he said last year when he
signed a landmark executive order on
competition and I quote the heart of
American capitalism is a simple idea
open and Fair competition but capitalism
without competition isn't capitalism
it's exploitation so I'll say one more
thing about the executive order it
establishes a whole of government effort
to promote competition in the American
economy because we know the lack of
competition leads to higher prices and
and worse service so uh again he you
know capitalism without competition
isn't capitalism it's exploitation and
that's why he's made he's really made an
effort with his executive actions to
deal with something that truly matters
to the American people
this is the same concern apply to Google
which is facing a new doj action today
uh look I'm I'm not going to get into
doj action or what doj is potentially uh
uh any legal matters that they
potentially are taking what I will say
is more broadly is how the president is
a proponent for increasing competition
in our economy and he has shown that
through his actions
on gun violence you've mentioned the
potential for further executive action
is there an active review underway of
other potential executive actions where
where is this being worked on within the
administration so don't have anything to
to share on any active review what I can
say is that the president has asked his
team to do all they can through
executive action to reduce gun violence
we've seen him make his historic
progress via VIA executive action to
deal with this dangerous uh violence
that we're seeing gun violence
specifically that we're seeing across
the country in dangerous hands so we'll
continue to pursue executive actions to
reduce gun violence don't have anything
right now to share or preview it list
out what is it that we're exactly
looking at but his team is always
looking at ways to improve uh to to deal
with an issue again that is devastating
communities across the country but I I
also want to be very very clear here in
order to deal with this we need Congress
to act and that's the way that we're
really going to be able to deal with a
matter that is again devastating
communities uh devastating families
across the country
undocuments I realize you don't want to
comment on existing issues but there is
clearly an ongoing issue uh across
administrations with the handling of
classified materials
um
perhaps this isn't the right time for
this White House to lead a review of U.S
policy on classified materials but is
that something that that the White House
is considering is there someone who
would be the right person to lead a
review of the current
um challenges that are obviously
tripping up people from all parties
understand the question and I know it's
going to come in many different ways but
I'm going to refer you to the White
House counsel's Office who would be the
best they would be the best folks to to
talk through about that
I want to follow up on Ukraine
um the Administration has been uh
relatively successful in forming
alliances not just in Europe but in Asia
as well Australia New Zealand and um
uh Japan uh against Russia of course and
imposing economic sanction but this is a
White House satisfied with the military
assistance that these countries are
giving I know you're gonna say it's a
sovereign state and they can decide for
themselves but at this point as we're
approaching the one year anniversary are
you satisfied with what you ask from
alliances to give to your Korean
militarily I mean look we've always been
very appreciative of our allies and
partners in their efforts to help
Ukraine and what they have decided their
security assistance is going to be for
Ukraine and so we will continue to be
appreciative we will continue to thank
them again and you said it in your
question to me it is a sovereign
decision it is up to each individual
country to decide how are they going to
do their part in helping Ukraine fight
against Russia aggression but you know
these are our allies these are our
partners and we will continue to to work
with them closely to to make sure that
ukrainians are able to to fight this
brutal War
we told them this alliances say that
last part the alliances are they still
holding we believe that they are I'm
gonna go I'm gonna come back down okay
Steve
it being the White House's position for
the last several weeks that the
president's legal team did the right
thing is it the initial observation of
the White House that the Pence legal
team did the right thing that's not for
me to to comment on from here I would
refer you to the Department of Justice
one of the things that the Pence team
seems to have done in the last week is
make public disclosure of this
circumstance uh advised Nara but also
advise Congress and now the public any
Reflections among the communications of
press staff here as to how the Pence
team handled it versus how
Steve I understand your question and I
hear it we've had we've answered your
question in many different variations
I'm I'm just not don't have anything
else to share from here if you have any
more specifics or details about this
about the ongoing legal matter I would
refer you to Department of Justice
anything else I would refer to the White
House council's office for two months
uh did uh does the white as a response
to Israeli Prime Minister netanyahu's
rise trip to Jordan today to meet with
England and do you think it could help
reduce tensions in the region uh I have
not seen those reports I've not been
able to talk to a National Security
Council about it uh but clearly we are
as you know uh Jake Sullivan just
recently went to Israel uh to meet with
his counterparts to continue the very
important relationship we have with
Israel just don't have anything further
it we normally don't comment on uh on
individual in countries meeting and the
agenda that they have with other
countries but don't have anything
specific to share on that you say
anything more about what's on the agenda
today with uh for the meeting at three
o'clock with um Democratic Leadership so
as you know the president is is very
much looking forward to meeting with the
new Democratic Leadership
and that is happening pretty soon uh
less than I don't even know less than an
hour
um and so he's going to host them in the
Roosevelt room you're going to hear from
him at the top he'll have something to
share about his thoughts about the
meeting they'll cover a wide range of
issues especially how we can make even
more economic progress on top of what
our shared accomplishments have led to
the creation of over 10.7 million new
jobs and 10 million small business
business starts bringing down inflation
and a record number of Americans
enrolling in HealthCare coverage one of
the main avenues for doing that is
ramping up implementation of the
legislation they accomplished together
over the past two years when you think
of inflation reduction now when you
think about the continuing
implementation of the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation that's what
one of the topics that certainly that
will come up and look the president has
said this he said this after the midterm
elections he said this many times I've
said this he's look he is he is looking
forward to working with Republicans in
good good faith to continue the work
that he has been able to do the last two
years some in a bipartisan way to
deliver for the American people but look
he's also going to call out as and we
have said this before continue to call
out any any dangerous extreme Mega
Republicans he can do both but like
proposals to raise taxes on the middle
class or cut Medicare cut Social
Security as we've been hearing from from
National Republicans or also I mean
let's not forget the national ban a
National Abortion ban or worsen
inflation and so those are the things
that the president is very focused on
and I think the most important thing
that I think you can take away from this
is he wants to continue to deliver for
the American people he's doing he's
willing to do that in a bipartisan way
but it has to be in good faith go ahead
um that was one of my questions about
the preview but one of the things I
wonder if the president has received
some democratic uh criticism about how
he has handled uh some of the things
that he has said about the documents
matter do you expect that he might
address that uh with the Democratic
leaders because it's obviously got
political implications for uh just how
he's perceived and and perhaps some of
his political strength going forward
yeah I kind of talked about this Kelly a
little bit yesterday and um some some of
those same criticism uh um from uh from
Democrats they also said the president
they believe the president did what he
needed to do and handled uh has handled
it fully and in a Cooperative way but
look you know as it relates to the
politics of this as it relates to the
American people uh and you know we'll
continue to say this it's up to the
American people to decide they you know
they're smart they know what's going on
they know what this president has been
doing and delivering on uh you know
we've talked about the mid terms and
what was supposed to be or what was
predicted to be and it didn't happen
right when you think about the red the
the the red wave that we had heard over
and over again and part of that why we
didn't see that is because the president
LED with a message that resonated and
connected with the American people he
led with what he has been able to do
when it comes to the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation when it comes
to making sure that we're he's doing the
work to lower cost at the gas pump which
he has been able to do and so look we
will let the American people see for
themselves what the president has been
able to deliver the last two years I'm
just not going to get into for into any
further discussion about specifically do
you know if he has been briefed on the
Pence matter and has he had any Outreach
with former president Obama since some
of the documents would have been from
their joint Administration you know
those two questions I would refer you to
the White House counsel's Office
thanks green after a special counsel was
named before the FBI searched
President Biden went to his house in
Wilmington what was he doing in there I
would refer you to the White House
Council so it was something relating to
this case I would refer you to the White
House council's Office okay do you think
that this story was leaked by someone
trying to bruise the president
politically ahead of a re-election
announcement I would refer to the White
House counsel's office as they've been
the ones who've been uh closely involved
okay more basically we know the
president did it why did he do it
I would refer to the White House
counsel's office and the president's own
words he admits to having information
that wasn't his why did he smuggle it
out I will let the the the statement of
the president stand for itself I'm just
not going to go into a rabbit hole down
a rabbit hole with you on this
thanks uh Haiti
um the UNM boy to Haiti has just been
saying today that it's basically out of
control and the gangs run while they
already run anything but they're in
charge
um can we expect any shift from the you
know any maybe Up Tempo of the U.S
response to this given not just
humanitarian side but maybe the National
Security aspect for the US so don't have
anything new to share uh on any um new
announcement or engagement uh look this
is something that we have been
monitoring very closely
and we have done uh you know everything
that we can to uh you know in this time
to help the Haitian people to help in a
way that could really make a difference
in the humanitarian uh Aid as you've if
you just laid out and um and I just
don't have anything else to share Beyond
uh what you laid out but this is uh
truly a um important to the president uh
and what's going on in Haiti uh and
you've heard us talk about it uh and you
know uh over the past several months you
heard the president talk about this at
nulls when he was in Mexico City when he
met with the Canadian Prime Minister
when he met with the president of Mexico
was clearly on the agenda and a
conversation that they had we had a
readout on that specifically it was
brought up uh in the in the press
conference that they had I just don't
have anything further to share
okay since you don't have any unsound
Declassified okay absolutely good fit
for this job go ahead go ahead go ahead
my friend
go ahead my friend
has any meeting been set between uh the
president and the speaker yet I don't
have a meeting uh to announce from here
with speaker McCarthy uh I know that it
is a we we've commented on this this is
something that the president is
certainly looking forward to uh and look
he's willing and wants to work with the
speaker in in good faith in delivering
in a bipartisan way for the American
people don't have anything to preview at
this time before after the state of the
Year this is something that he would as
you know it's tradition right for uh the
president to meet with the new Congress
before the State of the Union just don't
have anything to share at this time
it will happen
uh spoke about it it was in the context
of the deficit and debt having those
conversations is that sort of what the
engagement would be limited to or would
the president want to expand out the you
know you've talked a lot about gun
violence or the Border
so look there's going to be a range of
issues that's going to be discussed as
you mentioned when he was talking about
the deficit he was talking about wanting
to work in a bipartisan way to continue
to lower the the uh the debt right which
he has been able to do by 1.7 trillion
dollars in a historic record he's always
willing to have good faith conversation
to deliver for the American people in
that way but when it comes to look when
it comes to the the debt limit the debt
ceiling the president has been very
clear I have been very clear you've
heard from our economics team about that
how this should be done without
conditions that still stands and we
can't forget that and I talked about
this a little bit yesterday the debt
ceiling has been dealt with 78 times
since 1960 49 times under a president a
Republican president and 29 times with
the Democratic president and let's not
also forget I think this is something
that people who need to understand when
you talk about uh the debt ceiling
you're talking about out not more new
spending you're talking about what what
Congress the what the the bill that
Congress has racked up right this is
this is their basic Duty uh to you know
to deal with the debt ceiling uh when
the president walked in uh well if you
look at the debt ceiling right now 90 of
it was before the president uh walked
into office so this is their duty this
is their duty to do this in a bipartisan
way that's what we're talking about and
when you're when Republicans are saying
they're going to uh they're they want to
cut Social Security they want to cut
Medicare they want to cut
programs that Americans have paid into
that's going to hurt senior citizens
that's going to hurt our veterans that's
going to hurt taxpayers and so that's
what we're talking about and so it is
their basic duty to deal with this
okay Stephen oh thank you Kareem I have
two questions the first uh New York New
York Congressman Nick leloda is skipping
tonight's presidential reception for new
members of Congress in protest of White
House crude virus rules that require an
attestation of vaccination and a
negative test result lolota says the
rules are arbitrary and unscientific it
should be far behind us does the White
House have a reaction to that
um so I haven't seen those that
reporting or those comments from the
congressman but I'll say this we have
Protections in place to protect staff
and the president of the United States
covet isn't over we've been very clear
about that hundreds of Americans are
dying every day and cases are increasing
right now
today that's why we take Common Sense
measures like covet testing ahead of
large indoor Gatherings at the White
House and so this is an important an
important issue that's been important
when we're talking about covet and
dealing with covet and coming up with
Comprehensive ways to make sure that
people get vaccinated that's something
that the president dealt with from day
one of his administration
very briefly on that um I'm curious if
there was a reason that we still have
the vaccine attestation rule especially
considering the very highly
transmissible Omicron mutations that can
elude most of the common vaccines so
what I can tell you Stephen is we listen
to The Experts and we look at the data
and we you know we pay very close
attention to science and I just don't
have anything to do to to say beyond
that that is something that our experts
we take their advice when it comes to
things like that
regarding a comment from Senator Ted
Cruz he's calling for a search of
President Biden's Senate records at the
University of Delaware for potentially
classified information those records
reportedly include about
1850 boxes of documents as well as 415
gigabytes of electronic files does
President Biden have any objection to
such a search when it comes to the
documents and this ongoing legal matter
I refer to the White House counsel's
office would I just like to read
the request of our colleagues in this
room for someone to answer these
questions
absolutely okay
thanks I'll come to you go ahead
uh Kareen the oversight chair he had a
uh Mr Comey who wrote he wrote the head
of the Secret Service asking for the
visitor information from Wilmington now
I know you said there's no visitor logs
but do you have any objective or does
the White House have an objection to the
Secret Service providing any documents
or communication about who's going in
and out again I refer you to the White
House council's Office on on any any
anything that's related to the
investigation the oversight hearing
that's happening and then just at the
top in response to the Pence question
you said you weren't going to comment on
any ongoing criminal or other
investigations there's is there any
reason to believe any of these are
criminals I'm just saying I'm just not
gonna I'm just not gonna comment on any
type of investigation the Department of
Justice is independent and we just don't
comment on any any in investigations
from here
uh it's very clear to everybody that gun
is a problem in this country I'm gonna
give you an example in Africa when we
see news from the U.S like a six years
old boy bringing gun to school and we
see people going to the movie theater
being killed by gun and also seeing
people in this country that have not
seen War but are killed by gun is
extremely scared for us and we have seen
that this country is very developed what
do you think is preventing the Congress
to act when it comes to gun control and
what can more President Biden do to move
on and do something to control the gun
and my question comes because I'm a
mother I have two daughters and when
they go to school sometimes I'm afraid
that maybe his little colleague from
school will bring a gun or or even in
random place we we get shot this is very
very scared and this is a problem and
and we we saw recently people also Dying
by gun what can president do more to
move on and control the guns and please
what do you think that Congress is
waiting to act so when it relates to the
Congress you have to ask Congress you
have to go over to the con to Congress
and meet with Congressional members and
ask them that very question lay it out
just the way that you laid it out to me
I think it's an important question for
them to answer
but also we saw last night Senator
Feinstein along with Senators Murphy and
Blumenthal reintroduce the assault
weapons ban which we support and we
encourage for Congress to act on that on
that piece of legislation look again I
would refer I would suggest you go talk
to them about this look you just laid
out what I just said right you just laid
out about going to the movie theaters
and being worried about gun violence you
just laid out about being a parent and
worrying about your child going to
school or going to the grocery store and
worrying about gun violence that is
something that we should not have to
deal with and this is something again if
you look at the president's sent a
record as a senator you look at his
first two years as president he's dealt
with this issue and and he's going to
continue to do what he can from here use
the tools of the federal government to
take action he has taken historic
executive actions as I just laid out
moments ago but when it comes to really
truly dealing with this issue we need
legislation we need legislation we need
Congress to act so we are thankful and
we are hopeful to see what what occurred
with uh with this legislation that was
introduced Again by Senators Feinstein
Blumenthal and Murphy and we're going to
continue to encourage Congress to act
but I would I would pose the question
that you just asked me to Congress okay
just a follow-up week it's still on gun
violence uh we have spoke like between
me and some friends that are in this
country and this I'm making this point
because because we need to remind people
that America is the only country on
Earth that people die by gun without
even being on in war because I'm giving
this example because in Africa there is
countries in up in war but people
doesn't even have access to gun it's
very hard because the government and
everybody is very conscious that the
guns can cause a lot of Destruction but
in this country is very normal for
everybody to have access to gun and this
needs to be controlled but what can
people like me common people can also
what can we do to help control gun in
this country
well look what I can speak to there are
many ways that people can get involved
uh in in dealing with the gun violence
that we're seeing here I'm not going to
make any suggestions but there are ways
that folks can go out there and and uh
and participate uh in a way that's
healthy in the way that actually helps
deal with a real issue what I can speak
to is what the president has done what I
can speak to is what the president
believes what I can speak to is the
president's record on this which is you
can see for yourself as a senator this
last two years as president in the
executive actions that he's taken he
signed a bipartisan piece of legislation
as I just mentioned moments ago to deal
with in in taking one step to deal with
gun violence and so look that's what I
can speak to that's what we can talk
about very clearly and we're going to
continue to discuss and have the
conversation and call on a Congress to
act all right go ahead thanks friend we
heard you talk about the statements that
President uh put out but why haven't we
heard the president address the American
people on camera about these recent
shootings he's taken which one the
shootings that have happened recently
yeah I mean he has um
he's talked about it
um many times as you know
um and I'm sure you'll hear from him uh
in the upcoming days to uh to talk about
what he has seen and how devastating the
gun violence especially this week has
been
um and look you've seen him as I
mentioned in Uvaldi when he was
comforting the parents
of the kids who were who were murdered
you saw him in Buffalo
when he was again comforting families
who saw their family member murdered and
it's been too many
too many
and so you'll continue to hear from us I
think when the president puts out a
statement that is a very powerful
powerful action by by the president You
all take it you all repeat what the
president has said so I wouldn't I would
take that as a serious uh a serious
communication for the president as you
all already do and he'll continue to
speak out about it
spoken with the president about the most
recent report that more documents were
found at his home personally
former secretary Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo who in his new book and in a
tweet sent this afternoon has referred
to Jamal khashoggi as an activist and a
part-time Stringer so I'm gonna I'm
gonna let uh Mr Pompeo speak for himself
here's what I will say and what we uh
will say from the White House about this
about this issue from the earliest days
of this Administration we took the
murder of Jamal khashoggi very seriously
that included releasing intelligence
Community report on the murder which was
not done in the last Administration
sanctioning a number of Saudi officials
and entities and instituting the
so-called akashoji ban again I will let
Mr Pompeo speak for for himself
would you consider him an activist
I I'm not gonna get it he's
I'm not going to get into describing uh
Jamal khashoggi I can tell you how we
acted and what we have done over the
past two years and uh and be very clear
on what the White House has take the
actions that white house has taken okay
thank you so much another Africa
question for you today with me is that
the UN Ambassador is heading to the
continent and Janet Yellen is there
right now what messages are these two
top cabinet officials trying to send to
African countries broadly how do you
combat concerns and perceptions that the
continent is yet again being used as a
battlefield for a proxy war between east
and west and then also how do these
visits lay the groundwork for the
president's promised visit to the
continent and any details on that would
be awesome well to your last question
first
um uh don't have anything to preview
about the president's visit a potential
visit to uh to uh to to Africa we have
said that he is going to make a visit
just don't have anything to share at
this at this time so our partnership in
Africa is not about uh about Other
Nation
our partnership there it's uh as
demonstrated by our commitments at the
U.S Africa leader Summit the United
States sees African countries as genuine
partners and wants to build relationship
based on mutual respect that's what you
saw at the summit and that's what the
president has been consistent on and
that's what we want to see our focus is
on Africa and our efforts to strengthen
these Partnerships across a wide range
of sectors spanning from businesses to
health to peace and security building on
those efforts we've had secretary
blinken and secretary yellin travel to
the region very recently and as you
noted we have a Ambassador Linda Thomas
greenfields upcoming travel to Ghana
Mozambique and Kenya and that's going to
be from January 25th to the 29th
the ambassadors this is going to be the
ambassador's third trip to the
sub-Saharan Africa and and since she
took up her position at the U.S
ambassador to the United Nations she's
gone three times under this current
tenure that she's currently doing and
you will continue to see us uh following
through the president's commitment and
to step and to step up our engagement
across Africa this year and Beyond uh
and um look this is a commitment we saw
it when we put the summit together with
49.50 hesitates who are here right here
in DC and that was over three days and
the president participated in the
Summits his team participated in the
summit and we talked about issues that
really mattered to the continent and
issues that really mattered to us as
well sure why those specific countries
were chosen you just mentioned uh Kenya
Mozambique and Donna I would refer you
to uh the to the UN to the ambassador's
office as I said it's her third trip
right so she's gone two other times and
so I would refer you on to their
specific strategy on why these three
countries
okay Courtney thank you I wanted to ask
so um as you know this the president is
looking forward uh to releasing his
budget to the American people clearly
that's something that is important for
this president to do and the OMB his
team at the OMB is working very very
hard uh in in getting that done and
timing and obviously is his budget for
2024 uh and uh and don't have any don't
have a time for uh for when this is
going to to happen but again this is
something that he wants to make sure
that uh he uh he wants to share with
Congress and the American people and
it's a priority to him it used to be at
the beginning of February and when he
entered registration I don't think you
all have met that deadline yet or that
time frame yet does that have anything
to do with when last year's
Appropriations were done and what's
affected why you wouldn't have a data so
look the um the Omnibus the timing of
the Omnibus uh late last year certainly
has an impact on the budget timing but
certainly we'll be in touch with when
we're ready to share the president's
2024 budget thank you
thank you um thank you uh there was
reporting from Japan that the U.S
decided it will not deploy land-based
medium and intermediate range Mission
missiles to Japan can you confirm this
decision and say what is under
consideration in terms of where the
missiles will be deployed so according
to the Department of Defense there are
no plans to deploy capabilities to Japan
that range uh 500 that range Beyond 500
kilometers so I don't have anything more
to share I would refer you to the
Department of Defense
when the president speaks on the economy
later this week how much of that we'll
be talking about his own record and how
much he'll be warning about what
Republicans and Congress want to do such
as the sales tax so just a little bit of
what he's going to say as I announced
last week for those uh who may have
missed it on Thursday President Biden
will deliver remarks on the economic
progress we have made since he took
office the president will contrast his
plan to build an economy from the bottom
up in the middle out and to protect and
strengthen Social Security and Medicare
with the Congressional Republican plan
to cut Social Security Medicare and
other vital programs and impose a 30
percent national sales tax that will
increase taxes on Working Families his
remarks will uh will be in Springfield
Virginia with union workers who are
benefiting from his economic plan and so
we'll have more to share on that
tomorrow but again as you as you just
heard me lay out it's going to be a
contrast with what we're trying to do
and what the what the Republicans have
laid out but again the president has
always been very clear he's willing to
work in good faith within a bipartisan
way with Republicans to continue to
deliver on the economic successes that
you've seen from this Administration in
the last two years
um okay thank you okay
I want to ask about to follow up on the
story of Chinese companies providing
assistance for Russia did you have now a
few cents whether that Chinese
government is aware or approving this or
not and my second question is on Turkey
but can you please answer okay I'm sorry
can you say your first question again
it's just hard to hear about that
Chinese companies providing assistance
for Russia do you have a clear sense
whether that Chinese government is aware
of that or not so can't speak to to that
if the Chinese government is aware of
that or not we're closely monitoring the
situation as I just stated earlier as we
have been since the war started and we
will continue to communicate to China
the implicit implications of providing
material support to Russia's war against
Ukraine don't have anything specific on
what they know or not know but we're
certainly always communicating with them
and on Turkey yesterday president
erdogan said that Sweden should not
expect that turkey would stop foreign
how do you respond to his comment and
all and also to the incident so I talked
about this a little bit yesterday about
what how we see this and we have said
before uh many times before that Finland
and Sweden are ready to be NATO allies
that's how we see things both are
members of NATO's partnership for peace
and NATO's enhance opportunities
partnership their militaries work
seamlessly with alliances forces Finland
and Sweden have already taken concrete
steps to fulfill the commitments they
made under the trilateral memorandum of
agreement with turkey signed on the
margins of the NATO Summit in Madrid as
you all know and that includes
substantially strengthening their
bilateral cooperation with turkey on key
security concerns we continue to expect
that NATO will formally welcome Finland
and Sweden as members this will enhance
their security as well as that of the
euro science region so as their
membership process continues the United
States is fully committed to finland's
and Sweden's session the strength of
that support bless you can be seen in
our Senate's overwhelming bipartisan
support for vote for their membership
and that uh and so again that's uh
that's where we stand on that particular
matter okay go ahead thank you yeah uh
in the last several weeks this major I.T
companies like Google Microsoft Amazon
have fired thousands of I.T
professionals a significant number of
them are either Indian Americans or
Indian I.T professionals so two
questions these companies are saying
that a recession is on the horizon
that's why they're firing these people
does the president think that there is a
recession coming up and secondly these
Indian ID professionals who are an H1B
Visa they have to leave the country in
16 days these people who have their
families their kids standing here their
house and murder they're asking for more
time to stay here so that they can find
an alternative way to
so more broadly I'm just not going to
speculate why companies uh individual
companies uh have made specific
Personnel decisions that is for them to
speak to uh but you know you you don't
have to make take my word for it our
economy is continuing to grow in a
steady and stable manner as we have
you've heard us from here uh and you
just have to look at the economic data
when you look at the CPI data you look
at PPI uh and uh and so more broadly
again when it comes to economy layoffs
remain near record lows according to job
uh uh opening data again I'm just not
going to get into specifics or why this
is happening this is something for
individual companies to speak to and uh
and look the president has said this
many times he's going to do everything
that he can to make sure this is an
economy that works for everyone that
works from the uh from the bottom up
middle out and that's what you've seen
from his economic plans but you know the
president understands firsthand how the
impact of losing a job can have on a
family he understands that very
personally but just not going to get
into individual specifics the status of
those who have been fired how can they
can stay here in this country I don't
have any specifics on on that when it
comes to how they can stay here what I
can say is speak more broadly about what
we're seeing through the data what we
don't want to comment on individual
companies I can speak to what the how
the economy has actually been more of a
stable and steady growth because of the
president's actions hi
um heading into this meeting with the
Congressional Democratic leaders is
there anything you can tell us about the
relationship between President Biden and
Peter Jeffries obviously we know his
relationship with speaker Pelosi before
and he goes way back with Schumer but
what kind of relationship if any does he
have with uh
the president sees Congressman Jeffries
leader Jeffries as a vital partner in
this and is looking forward to
continuing to to work with the
congressman and and also is proud to
work uh with uh with uh with the
congressman closely as we uh as we uh
push forward on our shared agenda our
shared priorities in that 118th Congress
thanks everybody we'll see you tomorrow
thank you